♪♪
.
>> Judge Jeanine: DEMOCRATS ARE
GETTING UPSET THAT AMERICANS
AREN'T BUYING INTO THEIR MASSIVE
RADICAL SPENDING BILLS.
SO ARE THEY LOOKING INWARD AND
ASKING THEMSELVES WHY THEIR
AGENDA IS SO UNPOPULAR?
OF COURSE NOT.
NANCY PELOSI YESTERDAY WENT
AFTER THE MEDIA, BLASTING THEM
FOR NOT DOING THE DEMOCRATS' JOB
IN TRYING TO CONVINCE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO SUPPORT THE
RADICAL PROPOSALS.
>> DO YOU THINK YOU NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB AT MESSAGING AND,
GOING FORWARD, HOW DO YOU SPELL
THIS IF ULTIMATELY --
>> WELL, I THINK YOU ALL COULD
DO A BETTER JOB SELLING IT TO BE
VERY FRANK WITH YOU BECAUSE
EVERY TIME I GO THROUGH HERE I
GO THROUGH THE LIST, FAMILY
MEDICAL LEAVE, CLIMATE -- THE
ISSUES THAT ARE IN THERE.
BUT IT IS TRUE.
IT IS HARD TO BREAK THROUGH WHEN
YOU HAVE SUCH A COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE.
>> Judge Jeanine: WELL, YOU
KNOW, I LOVE THE FACT THAT SHE
SAYS, YOU KNOW, DO YOU THINK
THAT YOU NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB
OF COMMUNICATING WHAT OUR JOB IS
IN TRYING TO GET THIS BILL
PASSED.
SO IS THIS NOW LIKE AN OPEN
SECRET, DANA?
IS SHE OPENLY SAYING THAT THE
MEDIA IS A MESSENGER FOR THE
DEMOCRATS?
>> Dana: IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING.
OBVIOUSLY REPUBLICANS HAVE
REASON TO SAY THAT THE MEDIA IS
BAEZ, BUT IF YOU ASK A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS THEY THINK THE MEDIA
IS BAEZ AGAINST THEM AS WELL.
HILLARY CLINTON FOR SURE, WHEN
YOU COMES TO THE NEW YORK TIMES
AND THE CLEAN TON GLOBAL
INITIATIVE, THIS HE BROKE THE
STORY ALL THE E-MAILS.
SO I WOULD ALWAYS RECOMMEND, IF
YOU'RE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND
HAVE TO HIRE A PR PERSON, ALWAYS
HIRE A REPUBLICAN.
THEY'VE DEFINITELY HAD TO WORK
HARDER, THEY DON'T THINK ANYBODY
IS GOING TO BE HANDED TO THEM,
THEY HAVE TO BE MORE PERSUASIVE
IN THEIR LANGUAGE AND MORE
PROCEED SIZE IN THE MERITS.
NOTICE WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE TEXT
OF THE BILL?
GOOD REASON, BECAUSE AS SOON AS
YOU START LOOKING INTO IT,
PEOPLE ARE SAYING, WAIT, WE
DON'T REALLY LIKE THIS.
IT'S NOT A BENIGN ISSUE.
ALL THE POLLS ARE SAYING, WE
DON'T REALLY THINK WE NEED THIS,
WE DON'T THINK IT WILL HELP US.
SO THEY HAVE AN UPHILL BATTLE.
I JUST WANT TO MENTION A COUPLE
THINGS THAT ARE IN HERE.
JUST TO BE CLEAR FOR PEOPLE.
TALK ABOUT FREE CHILD CARE?
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
WOULD DO IS GIFT THIS GIFT TO
THE UNIONS AND THEY WOULD
REQUIRE ALL PRE KINDERGARTEN
PROVIDERS TO HAVE A COLLEGE
DEGREE.
>> RIDICULOUS.
>> Dana: DO YOU THINK THAT WILL
REDUCE THE COST OF CHILD CARE IN
AMERICA?
WE ALREADY HAVE A CHILD CARE
CRISIS.
AND THEY'RE DEMANDING HOW MUCH
THEY'RE GOING TO GET PAID?
THERE ARE ALREADY NOT ENOUGH
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND DO YOU
NEED A COLLEGE DEGREE?
YOU JUST DON'T NEED TO HAVE IT.
THE OTHER THING IS, IT WOULD
BLOCK FAITH BASED CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS FROM PARTICIPATING IN
THE PROGRAM AND THAT IS WRONG SO
THAT IS WHERE YOU GET THE
CULTURE WAR STUFF IN THE BILL.
PAY ATTENTION TO IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY, SO
GERALDO, SHE SAYS ONLY 10% KNOW
ABOUT WHAT'S IN THE BILL
>> Geraldo: I THINK THAT'S AN
EXAGGERATION.
>> Judge Jeanine: YEAH, I DO,
TOO.
BUT SHE SAYS, BUT IF THEY KNEW
WHAT WAS IN THE BILL, SHE'S
CONVINCED AMERICANS WOULD
SUPPORT IT.
>> Geraldo: LET'S TAKE THE
EXAMPLE THAT DANA MAKES ABOUT
THE PRE K.
WHAT IS PRE K?
I'M ALL FOR IT, YOU GET THE KID
AND YOU WANT THEM TO, YOU KNOW,
EVOLVE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND
BE AS READY FOR KINDERGARTEN AS
POSSIBLE.
PRE K BASICALLY IS DAY CARE,
RIGHT?
IN REALITY.
SO WHEN YOU INSIST THAT SOMEONE
HAS A DEGREE, A FOUR-YEAR DEGREE
TO BABY-SIT YOUR KID, OF COURSE
IT'S GOING TO JUST, YOU KNOW,
LARD EXPENSE ON -- AN IDEA, YOU
WANT UNIVERSAL PRE K GREAT.
BUT TO HAVE A COLLEGE DEGREE
UNNECESSARY.
NONE OF MY KIDS EVER HAD, YOU
KNOW, THAT PERSON, AND THEY GREW
UP FINE AND WENT TO GREAT
SCHOOLS.
>> Dana: NOT EVERYBODY HAS TO GO
TO COLLEGE
>> Geraldo: AND THAT'S THE OTHER
THING, NOT EVERYBODY HAS TO GO
TO COLLEGE.
AND ONE THING I WANT TO SAY IN
MY SYMBOLIC ROLE HERE AS
PROGRESSIVE, I THINK THAT --
DON'T YOU THINK THAT CINEMA AND
MANSION HAVE TO BE MORE BECOME
WHAT THEY WANT IN AND WHAT THEY
WANT OUT RATHER THAN MAKING
PEOPLE GUESS ABOUT WHAT -- I
THINK.
>> Dana: I THINK THEY'VE BEEN
VERY CLEAR.
>> Judge Jeanine: I WAS GOING TO
ASK GREG, WILL MANSION AND
SINEMA FOLD OR STICK TO THEIR
GUNS?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO WHAT PELOSI
SAID ABOUT THE MEDIA BECAUSE
IT'S AMAZING YOU CAN SAY THAT
WITH A STRAIGHT FACE BUT THAT'S
THE ADVANTAGE OF THE ADVANCES OF
MODERN MEDICINE.
IS IT HER FAULT TO EXPECT THEM
TO CARRY THE WATER?
I DON'T THINK IT IS.
SHE LOOKS ALTHOUGH THE MEDIA THE
WAY YOU LOOK AT THAT FRIEND THAT
PROMISES TO HELP YOU MOVE A
SOFA, AND THIS IS A HUGE,
MASSIVE SOFA, AND THEY HAVE JUST
GIVEN UP TRYING TO MOVE IT FOR
HER.
AND SHE'S LIKE, COME ON YOU
PROMISED YOU WERE GOING TO MOVE
THIS UP THE STAIRS.
SHE LOOKED AT THE MEDIA IN A WAY
THAT, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE IN THE
SAME CLUB.
SHE'S KIND OF RIGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: SHE IS RIGHT.
>> Greg: BUT I DO HAVE TO SAY
SHE DOESN'T BOTHER TO HIDE HER
ASSUMPTION OF SUPERIORITY.
SHE REALLY DOES SEE EVERYONE
ELSE AROUND HER AS LIKE
NON-PLAYING CHARACTERS IN A
VIDEO GAME.
LIKE SHE'S PLAYING THE GAME AND
EVERYBODY ELSE THERE IS JUST
THERE TO DEAL WITH HER.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY.
JESSE, AOC IS ACTUALLY WARNING
SCHUMER AND PELOSI SAYING YOU
CAN'T GET RID OF THIS, THIS AND
THIS SO IT LOOKS LIKE THE
PROGRESSIVES ARE AT WAR WITH
SOME OF THE MAIN STREAM
DEMOCRATS THERE.
SHE'S BASICALLY THREATENING
THEM.
IS SHE THE LEADER OF -- THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE?
>> JESSE: SHE HAS A LOT OF JUICE
AND YOU KNOW THE PROGRESSIVES
OUTNUMBER THE MODERATES SO SHE
MIGHT BE A LEADER IN SOME
REGARDS.
THE REASON THE MEDIA DON'T WANT
TO COVER THE DETAILS BECAUSE
THEY KNOW IF THEY DO NO ONE
WANTS IT.
LOOK AT THE DETAILS.
$25 MILLION FOR BUTTERFLIES.
WHAT DO THEY NEED MONEY FOR?
HOW ABOUT EIGHT BILLION FOR
CLIMATE POLICE.
I THOUGHT THEY WANTED TO DEFUND
THE POLICE.
NOT THE CLIMATE POLICE.
HOW ABOUT ILLEGAL ALIENS GET
FREE COLLEGE TUITION,
$643 MILLION FOR CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE FOOD.
WHAT IS THAT?
TACO TUESDAY?
EQUITY, EIGHT MILLION ILLEGALS
GET AMNESTY OR THEY'RE GOING TO
56 RACIST ROADS AND BRIDGES,
THAT PROBABLY MEANS THEY GET TO
DEMOLISH STATUS THEY DON'T LIKE.
ALSO MILLIONS IN GRANTS FOR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT TREAT
INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM
LONELINESS, JUDGE.
FROM LONELINESS NOW, PEOPLE THAT
ARE LONELY GET MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A